economía en francés 24 me acompaña en el
estudio jorge hurtado de nicaragua para
el mundo jorge vamos a comenzar en eeuu
para saber cómo se desarrollaron todas
las ventas de la temporada navideña en
este país bueno y vamos a empezar con el
'popular' cyber monday que se celebra el
día de hoy es el día popular de
promociones para el comercio electrónico
que le sigue al black friday que se
celebró el viernes pasado esta
convocatoria se veía afectada por las
interrupciones de la cadena de
suministro mundial que afecta a los
minoristas con escasez en los están en
las estanterías por ejemplo los datos de
ado analytics mostraron que el gasto en
línea durante el viernes negro cayó por
primera vez en la historia se espera que
el gasto de estado en eeuu durante el
cyber monday sea de entre 10 mil 200 y
11 mil 300 millones de dólares esto
según estimaciones de ado de cumplirse
de la previsión no habría un gran
aumento respecto a 2020 los descuentos
en eeuu previo al sector monday fueron
un 8 por ciento más bajos que el año
pasado según salesforce la temporada
navideña iniciado con la amenaza de omni
cron una nueva variante del cover 19 que
mantiene in sur en incertidumbre a los
mercados financieros globales
hablemos ahora de laos que es un país en
el sudeste asiático que extrañará
estrenará una extensa línea ferroviaria
que fue construida nada más y nada menos
que por china obviamente el vecino así
de santiago bueno este proyecto es de
aproximadamente 6 mil millones de
dólares y trae la esperanza a un país de
crear el impulso económico aunque las
críticas no se hicieron esperar esta
nueva ruta es de 414 kilómetros y
comenzará a operar el 3 de diciembre su
construcción tomó 5 años y es parte de
la multimillonaria iniciativa china
conocida como la nueva ruta de la seda
que financia proyectos de
infraestructura para aumentar la
influencia de beijing en el comercio
mundial la nueva ruta del tren conectará
la ciudad china de kunming con la
capital de laos a futuro se extendería a
través de tailandia y malasia hasta
singapur laos es un país de 72 millones
de habitantes y cuenta con escasez de
infraestructura antes del proyecto
santiago sólo tenían 4 kilómetros de vía
ferroviaria ahora cuentan con más de 400
un informe del movimiento la océano por
los derechos humanos reportó que la
construcción del proyecto obligó a 4 mil
400 agricultores y pobladores a dejar
sus y muchos esperar un largo tiempo
para recibir su remuneración
en laos el salario mínimo es de unos 116
dólares al mes mientras que el billete
de tren costaría 13 dólares de vientián
a la ciudad fronteriza de voten algo que
ha generado muchísimas críticas vamos a
escuchar ahora al embajador de china ahí
durante la inauguración
este progreso es un logro histórico para
la iniciativa china de la ruta de la
seda es una conexión estratégica que
transforma a lados de un país sin salida
al mar en un país conectado por tierra
hablemos ahora del líbano hay cientos de
personas se manifestaron por la grave
situación económica del país no levanta
cabeza así es decenas de manifestantes
bloquearon las vías principales de la
capital beirut y ciudades como trípoli
cidón y el valle de bbk el movimiento de
la el motivo de la protesta es la
inconformidad con varias políticas
gubernamentales es el alto costo de la
vida también por ejemplo la libra
libanesa se ubicó en 25 mil 800 por
dólar allí el salario mínimo es de 675
mil libras o sea 27 dólares
estadounidenses sumado a esto el
gobierno canceló varios subsidios al
combustible y a inicios de mes el
ministerio de salud también redujo las
subvenciones algunos medicamentos en ese
país de 6 millones de habitantes tres
cuartas partes viven en la pobreza la
crisis política y económica se agravó
con la pandemia y la explosión de agosto
2020 en el puerto de beirut que destruyó
parte de la capital el gabinete
conformado en septiembre no se reúne
desde hace seis en medio de divisiones
acerca de quién debe ser el juez que
investiga la explosión escuchemos un
poco el sentir de los manifestantes
protestamos porque la gente ya no puede
soportar esta difícil situación cuando
el valor del dólar alcanza las 25.000
libras libanesas hay gente que ya no
puede pagar la comida o la leche para
sus hijos ni los medicamentos para la
diabetes y la presión arterial para sus
padres qué esperas que hagan esto es el
comienzo de un movimiento
pasamos a los indicadores como las
faldas bolsas en la jornada de hoy
santiago arrancamos con wall street que
cerró en positivo después de que el
presidente yo bailé en descartar a la
necesidad de imponer confinamiento en
ese país a causa de la nueva variante
del coronavirus y las acciones europeas
subieron el lunes tras su peor venta en
el año ya que los inversores esperaban
señales de la variante de omicron en ese
continente y pasamos ahora a la cifra
del día para el cierre
bueno la cifra del día es 12 mil 300
millones de dólares ese es el patrimonio
neto de jack dorsey el fundador de
twitter door se anunció hoy que dejará
de ser el sello de twitter y dejó en su
lugar
barak agrawal
gracias ahora por esta actualización del
mundo económico siga con nosotros ya
había en el debate en france 24 buenas
noches
[Música]